[Music]
[Applause]
right
welcome to norway um this place houses
some of the best shellfish
anywhere on the planet and those waters
they're pristine
now i know it's only early afternoon and
we're losing light so i'm going to show
you
a norwegian king crab sandwich first off
when i get the legs and just literally
get the scissors and go through them
like that
and then with that make an amazing
little bird long okay let's get over to
the uh
the grill grab legs off
and then from there i'm just going to
grill
a little touch of olive oil on there
that's a touch now shallots in the pan
okay they've just been pickled gonna do
a really nice sort of
pickled shallot burr blonde
and then from there a touch of cream
in to the shallots just a touch
okay now start bringing that up to the
boil
the nice thing about the pickle shallots
is going to make it a little bit more
acidic
okay once you've reduced that it's
brought up to the boil
with a little touch of aqua okay which
is their
incredible botanical liqueur
which will put more hairs on your chest
than you'll ever need a touch of that in
there
beautiful
really beautiful trust me it doesn't get
any fresher than this
look at that
whisking that in
now that
starts to melt
that seaweed is going to act as a really
nice sort of
salt to that crab
we'll come to the legs now look i'm
gonna start open
beautiful
once the butter has melted
you'll see that really nice thick aqua v
delicious
and the secret is to keep it really nice
and acidic the norwegian king crab
are incredibly sweet so it needs that
kind of
acidity it needs that kind of
seasoning okay so on there
knock the butter in and literally just
straight up
just shake the pan and melt that butter
beautifully
and then to season it i've got some
seaweed salt here
right at the very end and that's going
to make it
sort of pop so
there you go they're delicious
amazing
now get your crab
[Music]
and then i'm just gonna quickly open
those buns
and lightly drizzle them with a touch of
oil
okay and lightly toast those buns
just get nice and crispy back on that
grill
beautiful
beautiful my bun's
nicely toasted the berb long is starting
to cool down and then from there look
pull open that open that up there
pull straight out and look at that
beautifully done
open that up
pull that back and then just
very carefully pull that off so those
little spines sit there this one
open it up there slice there let this
do the work the secret here is to make
sure
you don't let them cool down if you do
this when they're warm all that meat
just pops out
a lot bingo
beautiful prize
so tasty especially grilled like that
now just finishes off a little touch of
lemon zest
nice as soon as that
crab comes out of the shell and season
that with lemon
i'm going to sit that on there then
over here i've got some local parsley
and dill
chop that up
next to that a little touch of scallion
and then some pickled dill flour just to
give it a little bit of sympathy
in there so mix that up like a little
salad
and then i'm going to sit that on top
of my brioche
and then sit that back on top
of that bun
knuckle knuckle it's still nice and warm
this
and then get your sauce
and then literally just drizzle that
down
over there's a nice aquavit burp long
just remember again on this one
i want the acidity from the pickle
shallots
and then there
so
finally just a little touch of green
over the top
and there you go the most amazing
grilled
delicious norwegian king
crab sandwich trust me a sandwich to die
for
let me know in the comments what you
think of that amazing dish and if you
missed uncharted
trust me you can watch it on the link
below or
on the nat geo app